Now let's generalize.
Let's take the specific solver--we had a specific one
for the pouring problem and one for the missionaries and cannibals.
Let's generalize them. I'm going to call the generalization "shortestpathsearch."
That's a search for the shortest path that reaches a goal.
Let's take our inventory.
The concepts we have to deal with--we've got paths, states, actions, successors.
We have a start state. We have a goal.
Now let's figure out how we're going to represent each of these concepts.
Paths we already had. I don't see any reason to change.
We have [state, action, state...].
Notice we're just doing shortestpathsearch. We're not doing bestcostsearch.
We don't need to put in the total cost in here.
We can just have the action by itself.
We have states, and here the states can be atomic.
We don't have to know anything about the states.
In other words, a state can be anything
that a particular problem wants to deal with.
Shortestpathsearch doesn't have to know about that.
Now, why is that the case?
Because shortestpathsearch can interface with states through these two functions--
through successors and through the goal function and through the start state.
What do I mean by that? The start state is going to be some atomic state.
We don't know anything more about that. Shortest_path doesn't know anything about that.
When we go to use shortestpathsearch for a particular problem,
then we have to specify what a state looks like,
but shortestpathsearch itself doesn't have to know.
All it has to know is that if you give the start state to the successor function--
so successor will be a function which takes a state as input
and returns a dictionary of state-action pairs.
Now, given that initial state that we passed in,
we can generate new states and new actions.
So the actions also are atomic.
Shortestpathsearch doesn't have to know anything about the representation
other than that this is where they come from--from the successor function.
Now, what about the goal?
Well, we could specify an exact state that we're looking for,
but sometimes we're looking for multiple states.
We could specify a set of states, but sometimes the set of states is really big.
There's lots of states that satisfy the goal.
Instead, let's have the goal be a function.
Its's a function. When you pass it a state it returns a boolean.
True or False? Is that the goal?
With that now we're ready to specify shortestpathsearch.
Shortestpathsearch is going to be a function.
It's going to take some inputs, and it's going to return a path,
and return failure as a path if it can't find a solution.
Now the question is out of this inventory, which of these things do we have
to pass into shortestpathsearch to allow us to solve a problem?
Check all those that apply.